peter and matt can i take you on a
dexter ride for a minute because
i spent a lot of my life on dexter and
i'm
obsessed with it michael how many times
have you been approached
for a dexter revival and why was this
time different
i mean i've been approached unofficially
many times in the streets
by people who have ideas
but as far as i mean i think there have
been probably before this
three legitimate sort of
ideas or concepts about what we might do
and none of them just felt right
this one uh i think a lot of it has to
do with how much time has passed
you know i mean this is gonna happen in
in real time as if as much time has
passed
as has passed since the finale happened
and um yeah i mean we just kind of got
the creative band back together clyde
phillips um
is back who was the showrunner for the
first four seasons
um running the show and marco ciego is
one of our great directors is sort of
we're gonna shoot it like a long 10 hour
movie and um but um
yeah it was just i don't know it was a
combination of obviously the scripts
and the timing and
it just it just uh i i always thought
that maybe the time would reveal itself
when it made sense to do it and it did
and um i'm excited
i was just uh visiting the sets uh just
the other day and it's
real it's really what were your feelings
on
the series finale of dexter and and the
response to it
i mean i thought it
was completely um
from a storytelling standpoint like from
a character standpoint it made sense to
me
what he did but i certainly can
appreciate while it
why it left the majority of viewers
feeling a little
um left out in the cold or gypped or
frustrated because i mean he literally
didn't say anything at the end he'd been
talking to us the whole time and he just
stared at the camera and it was over and
he put his sister in the ocean and
what the hell was that so you know in a
way
the reboot is you know the the appetite
for the reboot
is is in a way facilitated by the fact
that it was a less than
sort of um satisfying ending for people
so um yeah i mean i i i want to
i want to find out what the hell
happened to the guy just as much as
everybody else
yeah it's it's like a weird blessing in
disguise right because if it was this
like perfect finale everyone be like i
don't want
this show to come back why would you do
this yeah
oh like everyone's like yes the show's
coming back we're getting more dexter
we're finding out what happened
yeah thank you for your patience what's
one thing that
you would personally like to see
addressed in the
the revival um
i i don't know if they're going to go
for it but i'm
angling for him to be running his own
pizza restaurant
just because you know i mean i don't
need to explain why that would be
awesome
um but i don't know i mean i'm kind of
low to say anything because i don't want
to give
anything away um right you already know
[Music]
you out of yeah misery
[Music]
cause darling you're dragging me down
let's take it all the way from the top
you guys met on broadway which you
normally don't hear about when
it comes to starting bands so uh take me
through the whole thing how did the
we should start a band combo come about
yeah hedwig on broadway
and then hedwig national tour i did it
with peter
and we were touring all over the country
eating a lot of tacos you know visiting
bathrooms all over the place and we were
like we got to just
you know keep playing music together and
make our own music
um not not rewritten music
we got back we jammed we it was all
instrumental stuff
um and then um i believe peter you
played it for
mike at some point yeah mike heard it
and
noticed we didn't have any vocals and
offered to come in and sing and
i think the next day he came by with his
notepad and wrote some lyrics
on the spot and the first princess song
was born and we just kept doing it
what's the story behind the name
princess goes to the butterfly museum
um there have been numerous ones uh
that i've heard but we went to this
party
uptown this was pre-covered back when we
had just started to make music together
and we i mean the only thing that
explains it in hindsight we didn't
confirm it but i think we all got
something slipped in our drink uh
hallucinogen and we
kind of freaked out and left the party
together or walking down central park
west and we got to around the natural
history
museum and matt was like you guys look
on the steps
you see what i see and we all kind of
collectively saw
this little princess walking up the
steps
opening the door and these butterflies
flew out i mean we saw it in our mind
and it coincided with the time we were
trying to come outside with a name
and um it kind of just was like a eureka
moment
so it was uh yeah that's how it happened
[Music]
so you guys were really in it like right
up until lockdown you were performing
and filming videos
what has it been like having this kind
of unintentional hiatus from touring
you know for all bands it's it's a drag
for sure
but it you know it forced us into
finding new ways to create and
and i think we all agree being in this
band
was a great uh sort of life raft
this year just being able to share ideas
sometimes we do it in our studio here in
union square or
or just sending each other tracks and
you know
we just sort of got creative and stayed
stayed engaged with each other and
so not being able to play live was sort
of gave us this other opportunity to
just
keep making music your ep came out in
2020. you know we put it out in last
april right when the pandemic
hit yeah the timing was maybe a little
less than ideal
but but hopefully um people will
will revisit it when the full length is
released in february and just it'll just
sort of just be a
a deluxe part of the record release are
you
you're planning on touring as soon as
you can yeah
absolutely whenever that is yeah we were
going to go out and play
at um harriet's actually that's perfect
yeah and that was supposed to be in i
think april
or something yeah obviously didn't
happen
but yeah we were going to record some
tunes out there
at rancho and play some tunes hopefully
that'll still happen
someday who do you think are your
biggest influences
in the music world or even beyond the
music world that you feel like
are present in this album bowie is
definitely an influence
uh i mean i'm among
so many i obviously second that um
blondie
who i've sworn with for the last i don't
know 12 or 13 years
they're an influence um and the way they
mix
you know keyboards and make them rock
and
electronics and pioneering that has sort
of rubbed off
on me i would say and i'll do a combo of
like
uh some black sabbath
meets georgio maroto well so i feel like
people are still kind of discovering
your band and you guys have fans from
all different
backgrounds all over like peter
morningwood wallflowers matt we have
blondie michael dexter six feet under
what's the number one thing that people
ask you or say to you
after a show mostly they ask if we do
bar mitzvahs
to which the answer is yes
yes yeah
so and when are you playing again and
when are you going to release music
which is always a good
sign i mean unless they're like i want
to get that record and
break it over my banister anyway
yeah yeah and and and it's exciting that
you know we we started playing well
before we were releasing anything so
like the only way
to hear whatever we were up to was to um
come to a show so
i'm glad that we're going to be able to
you know give some people some music
that they can listen to without coming
to see us because they can't
come to see us
you